Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告诉大家一个现在正在发生的激动人心的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造为你赚钱的收入，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are looking at trauma. We are looking at how you can
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一交流一小时的辅导。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个快速私信，我会把所有详细信息发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨创伤。我们将探讨你如何
experience personal trauma and then begin to make it your clinical specialty. It is a fascinating episode. It's not every day we can say the podcast has featured a Paralympian. So it's a very special episode and I hope you'll find it useful. I had to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. Hope that you are well wherever you are listening to this in the country, in the UK, or indeed the world. Please do come and let me know a little bit about yourself by coming along to the free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. And do come and follow me on socials. If you're watching on YouTube, you can do that by scanning the QR code on screen now. If you're not watching on YouTube,
经历个人创伤，然后开始将其发展为你的临床专业领域。这是一个迷人的节目。我们不是每天都能说播客请到了一位残奥会运动员。所以这是一个非常特殊的节目，我希望你会觉得它有用。你一定正在通往获得资格的路上。这里是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。你好，欢迎收看《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。希望无论你在英国的哪个地方，还是世界的哪个角落收听这期节目，你都一切都好。请一定要来，通过加入免费的 Facebook 群组“有抱负的心理学家社区（与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起）”来让我对你多了解一点。一定要在社交媒体上关注我。如果你正在 YouTube 上观看，现在就可以通过扫描屏幕上的二维码来做到这一点。如果你没有在 YouTube 上观看，
please do just search for Dr. Marianne Trent on whichever social platform you're on. And I should appear as if by magic. One of the things that I have done in my professional career over the last few years is to get a little bit more confident in talking about myself publicly. That is something that I started to do in the Grief Collective book. It's something I continued in the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, and also something that I've continued in the membership and for that matter in these podcast episodes too but it does take confidence and it takes time and we need to make sure that we're not just talking about ourselves all the time because that's not that useful for our clients What we need to do is strike a balance and to know why we're sharing
请在你使用的任何社交平台上搜索玛丽安·特伦特博士。我就会像变魔术一样出现。在过去几年里，我在职业生涯中所做的事情之一，就是变得更加自信地公开谈论我自己。这是我在《悲伤集体》（Grief Collective）书里开始做的事情。这也是我在《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）书里继续做的事情，同时也是我在会员群里以及在这些播客节目中一直在做的事情，但这确实需要自信，也需要时间，我们需要确保我们不是一直在谈论自己，因为这对我们的 clients（客户）来说并不是那么有用。我们需要做的是取得平衡，并知道我们为什么要分享
our personal story to really make sure that it's of benefit to what we're talking about with the client. Now, I sort of stumbled into working with trauma as my clinical specialty because that's what was being delivered in the service I was working in and it just really resonated with me. But we all start in our journey for clinical specialties with different reasons, different motivations. And today's guest has a very interesting reason for why trauma was right for her clinically and how it all unfolded. It is a fascinating episode. It does feature an ex-Paralympian athlete and it was just such a pleasure to speak with Dr. Yvonne. I hope you'll find it really, really interesting for a variety of reasons and I would love to know
我们的个人故事，以真正确保它对我们与客户所谈论的内容有所帮助。现在，我算是无意中开始从事创伤工作并将其作为我的临床专长的，因为那正是我当时工作的服务机构所开展的业务，而且它真的引起了我的共鸣。但我们所有人走上临床专长之路的最初原因和动机各不相同。今天的嘉宾有一个非常有趣的理由，解释了为什么创伤对她来说在临床上是正确的，以及这一切是如何展开的。这是一个迷人的节目。它确实有一位前残奥会运动员出镜，与伊冯博士（Dr. Yvonne）交谈真的是一种绝对的 prazer（荣幸）。我希望出于各种原因你会觉得它非常非常有趣，并且我很想知道
what you think of the episode. Please do come and let me know and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side once you've been introduced to Yvonne. Hope you find it useful. Just want to welcome along our guest today Dr Yvonne Woff is a clinical psychologist. She's also an author of a really lovely new book which is out now and it's called Coping with Trauma. But more than that, she's also a retired Paralympian. It's not every day that we can say that we've got an Olympian on the podcast. Welcome along, Yvonne. Thank you very much, Marianne. It's lovely to be here. Thank you for having me on. Oh, thank you for coming. And, you know, this is a case of us having known each other and known about each other for a while. We're Facebook friends. We've been in the same Facebook groups probably quite a few years now, but we've never actually met in person.
你对这期节目的看法。请一定要告诉我，一旦你认识了伊冯，我很期待在另一端与你交流。希望你觉得它有用。只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾伊冯·沃夫博士（Dr Yvonne Woff），她是一名临床心理学家。她也是一本非常棒的新书的作者，该书现已出版，书名为《应对创伤》（Coping with Trauma）。不仅如此，她还是一位退役的残奥会运动员。我们并不是每天都能说我们的播客里有一位奥运选手。欢迎你，伊冯。非常感谢，玛丽安。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你邀请我来。哦，谢谢你的到来。而且，你知道，我们俩可以说是早就认识对方并了解彼此了。我们是 Facebook 好友。我们可能在同一个 Facebook 群组里待了好几年了，但我们实际上从未在现实生活中见面。
So it's really nice to have you here. And you had approached me because of your passion for working with trauma and because of your new book and we will come on to talk a little bit about your book in good time but yeah I really want to get a flavor introduce our audience to to who you are what your journey with psychology has been and I know some of that might tread on some territory of your book as well but something else I didn't say about you in your intro is that you're a wheelchair user yeah absolutely that kind of weaves in some of your trauma story um and also your psychology story as well can I let you um guide us through a little bit about that, if that's okay, Yvonne? Yeah, absolutely. So it's all in the book. There's no big secrets here. So I became a
所以很高兴能在这里邀请到你。你联系我，是因为你对从事创伤工作充满热情，也是因为你的新书，我们稍后会有充足的时间来谈论你的书，但是，是的，我真的很想了解一下，向我们的观众介绍一下你是谁，你的心理学之旅是怎样的，我知道其中有些内容可能也会涉及你书中的一些领域，但我没有在你的介绍中提到的一点是，你是一名轮椅使用者。是的，绝对的。这其中交织着你的一些创伤故事，嗯，还有你的心理学故事。能让我请你，嗯，跟我们稍微讲讲这方面的事情吗，如果可以的话，伊冯？好的，没问题。所以这些都在书里。这里没有什么大秘密。所以我成为了
wheelchair user at the age of 19. I had a very nasty run-in with meningitis and septicemia. So I lost both legs, actually, which was pretty traumatic for a 19 year old girl back in the mid 1980s. I thought I knew which way my life was going at that point. And then all of a sudden I had to do a complete rethink about life and everything. I think, as you say, I got into sport. I played wheelchair basketball for many years to international level. And it was really through doing that that I started to see role models, people, other people who were further along that journey of being disabled adults, really,
轮椅使用者是在我 19 岁的时候。我跟脑膜炎和败血症有过一次非常糟糕的交锋。所以我其实失去了双腿，对于 20 世纪 80 年代中期的一个 19 岁女孩来说，这相当具有创伤性。那时我以为我知道我的人生正朝哪个方向发展。然后突然之间，我不得不对生活和一切进行彻底的反思。我想，正如你所说，我接触了体育。我打了多年轮椅篮球，达到了国际水平。真的正是通过这项运动，我开始看到榜样，看到其他人，那些作为残疾成年人在这条路上走得更远的人，
that enabled me to see a future for myself, really, through coming out of trauma and into life as a disabled adult. And yeah, gradually through that process, I got myself back to university, studied psychology. I think there was an unconscious process in that happening, in that having not probably had as much psychological support as I needed adjusting to my new circumstances at 19 I really felt the lack of that and I wanted to understand myself better I had also had quite a tricky childhood prior to that with you know not the most compassionate empathic parenting and so so, you know, emotionally, things have been quite difficult for me, I think growing up and then adjusting to disability,
这让我真正能够通过走出创伤、进入残疾成年人的生活，为自己看到一个未来。是的，通过这个过程，我逐渐回到了大学，学习心理学。我想其中发生了一个无意识的过程，那就是在 19 岁时适应我的新环境时，可能没有得到我所需要的足够的心理支持，我真的感到了这种缺失，我想更好地了解自己。在此之前，我也有过一个相当棘手的童年，你知道，没有得到最富有同情心、最有同理心的育儿照顾，所以，你知道，在情感上，对我来说事情一直相当困难，我想在成长过程中然后适应残疾，
I didn't really have the tools. So sport was the first way that I started to adjust to things and started to see the possibilities. As you say, I then eventually went to the Atlanta Paralympics in 1996 as a wheelchair basketball player for the GB women's team and that was an amazing experience. And I suppose that that sort of journey started me to have real confidence in myself and my abilities and alongside that I then got back into education. So I was doing my psychology degree. I was becoming more and more fascinated. The more I learned about psychology, the more I, I suppose, learned about myself, applying what I was learning to myself. And I really wanted to go into clinical psychology at that point.
我真的没有工具。所以体育是我开始适应事物并开始看到可能性的第一种途径。正如你所说，我后来终于作为英国女子轮椅篮球队的一员，参加了 1996 年的亚特兰大残奥会，那是一次令人惊叹的经历。我想那种旅程开始让我对自我和自己的能力产生真正的自信，与此同时，我重新回到了教育界。所以我当时在攻读我的心理学学位。我变得越来越着迷。我对心理学了解得越多，我想我对自己的了解就越多，将我所学的知识应用到自己身上。那时我真的想从事临床心理学。
And then, of course, that journey sort of unfolded. So I was a mature student at undergrad. I was, I think, 27 or 28 when I started my undergrad, because obviously I'd had this interruption previously. So I came out of my undergrad at just just about 30 or so and was getting married around that time and then went on to have my daughter so sport kind of got put on hold. And I had my daughter and then kind of started focusing on the clinical psychology career and came up against quite a few hurdles with that I think. You know, accessibility to roles, being turned down at interview because, well, home visits are needed in this role, so you won't be able to do that, so sorry, but no. There were a lot of things that came up along that journey. I had an assistant psychologist post in a department where the weekly psychology meeting
然后，当然，这段旅程就这样展开了。所以我在读本科时是一名成熟的学生。当我开始读本科时，我想我 27 或 28 岁了，因为显然我之前有过这种中断。所以我读完本科时差不多刚好 30 岁左右，那时正准备结婚，然后接着有了我的女儿，所以体育事业算是被暂时搁置了。我有了女儿，然后就开始专注于临床心理学的职业生涯，并且在这一过程中遇到了相当多的障碍，我想。你知道，角色的可及性，在面试时被拒绝，因为，嗯，这个角色需要家访，所以你做不到，所以对不起，但是不行。这一路上出现了很多事情。我在一个部门有一个助理心理学家职位，那里的每周心理学会议
was in a room upstairs and I had no access to that so I was just excluded from the psychology meeting um so yeah there were there were lots of things along that journey that that were difficult and kind of sucked it up I think I sucked up a lot of ableism on that journey um because I really wanted to be a clinical psychologist, but it really shouldn't have been as hard as it was at times. So then I did eventually get onto the clinical doctorate, and again, faced quite a lot of ableism there as well. So I experienced a lot of ableism along the journey, and I, you know, I don't really know what the answer to that is, other than, you know, that needs thinking of thinking about at a systemic level at, you know, the sort of level of the trainers in clinical psychology. Because, I mean, for example, the course I attended, the clinical doctorate that I attended at Leeds, when I attended it, the course office was in a building that I couldn't access
在楼上的一个房间里，我无法进入，所以我被排除在心理学会议之外了。所以，是的，这一路上有很多事情是困难的，而且我咬牙挺了过去，我想我一路上忍受了大量的健全主义，因为我真的很想成为一名临床心理学家，但有时事情实在不该这么艰难。后来我终于进入了临床博士项目，同样，在那里也面临了相当多的健全主义。所以我一路上经历了大量的健全主义，而我，你知道，我真的不知道除了，你知道，这需要在系统层面进行思考，在临床心理学培训师的层面进行思考之外，答案是什么。因为，我的意思是，例如，我参加的课程，我在利兹（Leeds）参加的临床博士课程，当我参加时，办公室在一栋我无法轻易进入的建筑里，
easily, if at all, and parking at the teaching venue was very very difficult but I couldn't physically get a train into Leeds at that time to attend training. So there was a lot that I had to deal with and then moving from placement to placement every six months, you know, when you've had to argue for some reasonable adjustments in your workplace, and then you move to another workplace six months later, and you've got to start again, trying to get, you know, just basic access requirements in place and finding out where the accessible loos are. you know sometimes that's not in the department that you're based in and yeah just so many so many challenges along the way
如果说还能进得去的话，而且教学地点的停车非常非常困难，当时我无法亲自坐火车去利兹参加培训。所以我不得不应对很多事情，然后每六个月从一个实习地点换到另一个实习地点，你知道，当你不顾一切地在工作场所争取一些合理的调整，然后六个月后你又换到另一个工作场所，你必须重新开始，努力去获得，你知道，仅仅是基本的无障碍设施要求到位，并弄清楚无障碍洗手间在哪里。你知道，有时那不在你所在的部门，是的，一路上有太多的挑战，
and also as I as I said not only was the disability stuff which I kind of took on myself to deal with a lot I really did have a lot of internalized ableism going on and you know kind of took it as my responsibility to sort that sort of stuff out. I also had a two year old toddler when I started training. And that was really hard to being a parent, being the only parent in my cohort, being older than most of my cohort and trying to juggle childcare needs, you know, getting back from placements that could be all over the place in time for nursery shutting. I had a big argument at one point with the course placements officer because they wanted to place me, so I was living near to Wakefield at the time in West
而且正如我所说，不仅是残疾方面的事情，我不得不自己承担很多来处理，我身上其实一直在发生很多内部化的健全主义，并且，你知道，把解决这类事情当成是我自己的责任。我开始培训时还有一个两岁的小幼儿。这真的很艰难，作为一个父母，成为我这一届中唯一的父母，比我这一届大多数人年龄都大，还要努力兼顾育儿需求，你知道，从可能到处都是的实习地点赶回来，赶在幼儿园关门前接孩子。我曾与课程实习官员有过一次激烈的争论，因为他们想给我安排一个实习，我当时住在西约克郡韦克菲尔德（Wakefield）附近。
Yorkshire. And they wanted to give me a placement in Huddersfield, which would be over an hour's drive away, because it was the other side of Huddersfield from where I was. And so the travel would take me over an hour. Now my nursery time, my child was in nursery in Wakefield at the time, near to the main mental health hospital in Wakefield. So what I would have to do is drive from my village near Wakefield to Wakefield, drop my daughter off and then drive over an hour to the other side of Huddersfield. And I said, I literally can't do it because the hours don't allow, you know, I can drop her off at 8am, I can pick her up no later than 6pm. If you want me to work nine to five in
他们想在哈德斯菲尔德（Huddersfield）给我安排一个实习，开车需要一个多小时的车程，因为那是哈德斯菲尔德离我住处较远的那一边。所以路程会花我一个多小时。现在我的幼儿园时间，我的孩子当时在韦克菲尔德的一家幼儿园，靠近韦克菲尔德的主要精神健康医院。所以我必须做的是从我韦克菲尔德附近的村庄开车到韦克菲尔德，放下我的女儿，然后开车一个多小时去哈德斯菲尔德的另一边。我说，我真的做不到，因为时间不允许，你知道，我可以早上 8 点送她去，我最晚下午 6 点接她。如果你想让我在
this placement, it doesn't add up. And what they wanted to do was to get someone who lived in Huddersfield to travel to Fieldhead Hospital in Wakefield for a placement at that same time. And I had a conversation with that person and said, you live like five minutes from St Luke's Hospital in Huddersfield. I'm dropping my child off less than five minutes away from Fieldhead Hospital in Wakefield. Can we not just swap placements? And we spoke to the placement supervisor and they said, no, you can't.
这个实习里朝九晚五地工作，这根本对不上。而他们想做的是找一个住在哈德斯菲尔德的人，同时去韦克菲尔德的菲尔德黑德医院（Fieldhead Hospital）实习。我和那个人进行了对话，我说，你住在离哈德斯菲尔德圣卢克医院（St Luke's Hospital）大约五分钟路程的地方。我送孩子的地方距离韦克菲尔德的菲尔德黑德医院不到五分钟。我们难道不能直接交换实习地点吗？我们和实习督导谈了谈，他们说，不，你们不能。
And I said, well, I can't do that placement, end of. I said, I have to pick my child up by 6 p.m. I started quoting all sorts of like, have you heard of attachment theory? You know, these are very senior psychologists, you know, have you not heard of attachment theory? You know, I have to pick my child up, I can't leave her at nursery. So yeah, there was there were all sorts of wrangles like that about, well, both childcare and disability. So I really had a double whammy of challenges um going on through my training journey you know both as before training and
我说，好吧，那个实习我做不了，就这么定了。我说，我必须在下午 6 点前接我的孩子。我开始引用各种像这样的理论：“你们听说过依恋理论吗？”你知道，这些都是非常资深的心理学家，你知道，“你们难道没有听说过依恋理论吗？”你知道，“我必须去接我的孩子，我不能把她留在幼儿园。”所以，是的，有各种各样的争论，关于育儿和残疾。所以我在培训之旅中确实经历了双重挑战，你知道，既有培训前也有
through training um and then post-training really as a clinical psychologist working in the NHS where there wasn't that much flexibility in terms of working hours. Yeah, you could go part-time, but you were still expected to be in the department nine till five on the days you were working. And as a parent, you'll know yourself, you've got kids, you know, it's hard to do that nine to five because it forces you into doing all the child wrangling sort of early in the morning, get them to school, get yourself to work. It's really tough, isn't it? And then the same wrangling sort of early in the morning get them to school get yourself to work it's really tough isn't it and then the same at the other end of the day um it was really hard to get that flexibility and add into that that not only am I disabled but my daughter actually has
培训期间的，然后是培训后，作为一个在 NHS（国民 NHS）工作的临床心理学家，工作时间没有那么大的灵活性。是的，你可以做兼职，但你仍然被期望在你工作的日子里朝九晚五地待在部门里。作为一个父母，你自己也会懂，你也有孩子，你知道，要做到朝九晚五很难，因为它迫使你在清晨做所有应付孩子的事，送他们去学校，让自己去上班。这真的很艰难，不是吗？然后一天的结束时也是如此，要获得那种灵活性真的很难，再加上不仅我是残疾人，我的女儿实际上也
disabilities as well she has um a perinatal brain injury sadly um that's caused her a lot of difficulties she's 22 now and she's doing great um but you know there were times you know at those early stages in her life where it was really challenging it was a lot to kind of deal with and you know I was dealing with that as a disabled person myself um so the levels of stress on top of stress that I was dealing with and then you know doing a really stressful job. Clinical training, as you know, is incredibly stressful. And working as a psychologist in the NHS post-training is really stressful. It's a hard job. And really, the answer to all of that came
有残疾，她不幸患有围产期脑损伤，这给她带来了很多困难，她现在 22 岁了，过得很棒，但在她生命的早期阶段，确实有那么一段时间非常具有挑战性，需要应对的事情很多，你知道，我是作为一个残疾人自己在处理这些事情，因此，我正在应对的压力之上的压力层级，然后，你知道，还要做一份压力非常大的工作。正如你所知，临床培训压力极大。培训后在 NHS 作为心理学家工作压力也很大。这是一份辛苦的工作。真的，所有这些问题的答案
much later on, around about, I mean, I trained 2003 to 2006. I went, I started doing a little bit of private work around 2013. So about, you know, sort of six, eight years after, after finishing training, I went into a bit of private practice and very rapidly thought this is where I belong. And there was a bit of a transition period of a couple of years but by 2016 I was fully in private practice and can pick and choose my hours now pretty much you know I have so much more freedom now and so much more freedom to choose what work I do as well and to develop in the directions I want to develop which is just amazing it's an amazing luxury I went through a lot of hardship early on
来得很晚，大约在，我的意思是，我是在 2003 到 2006 年接受培训的。我在 2013 年左右开始做一点私人工作。所以在完成培训大约六、八年后，我进入了私人执业，并且很快就认为这才是属于我的地方。经过了一段两年的过渡期，但到 2016 年，我完全投入了私人执业，现在几乎可以挑选我的工作时间，你知道，我现在有了更多的自由，有更多自由去选择我做什么工作，并朝着我想发展的方向发展，这简直太棒了，这是一种惊人的奢侈。我的职业生涯早期经历了许多艰难困苦，
in the career but i've got to a place where i have so much freedom and you know ability to earn and yeah it's it's just so so freeing now being in private practice and being a supervisor and being a an emdr facilitator on training um I've just got so much freedom now compared to what I had back then so I would say the struggle was worth it but it was very hard at times it was way harder than it needed to be at times wow Yvonne like what a lot you know to go from being able-bodied 19 living you know living your life independently um to then sort of almost waking up and having to experience that you are now going to be a wheelchair user you know not have the chance to even say goodbye to your
但我已经到了这样一个地步：我拥有如此多的自由和赚钱的能力，并且，是的，现在身处私人执业、作为一名督导、作为培训中的 EMDR 催化剂，感觉是如此的自由，相比于我当年的情况，我现在拥有太多的自由。所以我会说，这些挣扎是值得的，但有时确实非常艰难，有时比本来需要的要艰难得多。哇，伊冯，真的有太多的事情了，你知道的，从一个身体健全、 19 岁独立生活的你，过着自己的生活，然后几乎像是醒来后不得不经历你现在将成为一名轮椅使用者，你知道，甚至没有机会跟你的双腿说再见，你知道你当时并不知道那会发生，那真的是太多了，真的是太多了。然后，你知道，听起来有那么多被边缘化的经历，你知道，而且几乎是你也在边缘化你自己，因为你
legs you know you didn't know that was happening um that's a lot that's a lot and then you know it sounds like there's so many experiences of being othered you know and almost you were othering yourself as well because you yeah you know probably had your own preconceptions about what wheelchair users were like and you know because you experience you know what you experience and you know that's been our norm that's been your norm and then suddenly you're having to enter this whole realm of other stuff you know um and I I had myself kind of imagining and thinking actually when you were joining and you know spending time with all of the other women in the basketball team that must have been incredibly liberating you
可能对轮椅使用者是什么样的有着你自己的先入之见，你知道，因为你经历着你所经历的，你知道那是我们的常态，那是你的常态，然后突然间你不得不进入这个充满其他事物的广阔领域，你知道，而且我自己在脑海中想象并思考，实际上当你加入时，你知道，和篮球队里的所有其他女性共度时光，那一定是非常解放的，你
must have learned so much about them about how to be confident as a wheelchair user and some of those might have been wheelchair users from birth and others might have been from accident or illness as well um yeah I feel like that's a really great learning zone to to really learn absolutely I mean one of the things I talk about a little bit in my book coping with trauma is the importance of finding your people you know um finding the people who you can connect with who can be supportive of you who can show you the way even you know um I think there's so much more available now in terms of social media um which can be a blessing and a curse i think um but back in the mid 80s there was very little access to information and actually for me you know going into wheelchair basketball um
一定从她们身上学到了很多，关于如何作为一个轮椅使用者建立自信，其中一些人可能是天生就是轮椅使用者，而另一些人也可能是由于事故或疾病造成的，你知道，我觉得那是一个非常棒的学习领域，去真正学习。绝对的，我的意思是，我在我的新书《应对创伤》中谈到的一点，就是找到你的同类的重要性，你知道，找到那些你可以与之联系、能够支持你、甚至能为你指明道路的人，你知道，我认为现在在社交媒体方面有更多可用的资源，这既可能是福也是祸，我想，但在 20 世纪 80 年代中期，获得信息的途径非常少，实际上对我来说，加入轮椅篮球，
and finding people who were working i didn't know that was an option at first. People who had careers, people who had married and had families. I mean, I was 19. I didn't know, you know, I thought I might want to get married and have children at some point, but I didn't know, you know, when something dramatic like that happens, you don't know if that's still an option for you. You know, ever love me that was probably a question on my mind at some points back at that stage um and then to get into wheelchair basketball and see people that were married and parenting or you know sort of um just living their lives in whatever way they wanted to you know um that was just so liberating to see that you know I didn't have to have my options limited just because I was now a wheelchair
并找到那些正在工作的人——起初我不知道那也是一种选择。那些拥有职业的人，那些结婚并组建家庭的人。我的意思是，我才 19 岁。我不知道，你知道，我想我可能在某个时候想结婚生子，但当发生如此戏剧性的事情时，你并不知道这是否依然是你的一个选择。你知道，“会有人爱我吗？”那可能是我那个阶段某些时候脑海中的一个问题，然后进入轮椅篮球，看到那些结了婚、为人父母的人，或者，你知道，以他们想要的任何方式过着自己生活的人，你知道，那看到这些真的是太解放了，你知道，我不需要仅仅因为我现在的轮椅使用者而使我的选择受到限制
user um yeah it was it was it was finding my people and making those connections and then you know the friendships that grew out of that you know some of those people um that I was connected with then you know I may have gone big chunks of time in my life without speaking to them but then you know we'll meet up at you know because I coach wheelchair basketball now I don't still play but I do still coach and I'll bump into people that I've not seen for 20 or 30 years who I used to play with or against back then. And it's just like, you know, it's like we spoke yesterday. You know, we just pick up conversations and just catch up.
使用者，你知道，是的，这就是找到我的同类并建立那些联系，然后从那之中成长起来的友谊，你知道，那些我与之建立联系的人，你知道，我可能在生命中经历过很长一段时间没有跟他们说话，但后来，你知道，我们会聚在一起，因为我现在担任轮椅篮球教练，我虽然不打了，但我还在执教，我会偶遇那些我 20 年或 30 年没见过的、曾经一起打过球或作为对手的人。那感觉就像，你知道，就像我们昨天刚聊过一样。你知道，我们只是重新开始对话并叙叙旧。
And it's just lovely to have those those sort of connections. But that's that's been such a powerful healing part of my journey to have those connections absolutely. I'm so pleased that you you know had a go at wheelchair basketball and then that that ended up happening for you because that sounds like you got just what you needed when you didn't even maybe really know that you needed it and it's been transformational for you um and it just it sounds wonderful I'm so pleased that you had that and had that experience um and also when you were talking about your experiences of being an assistant psychologist and then your experiences of being a trainee just sounds horrendous and being a parent you know so I trained shortly after you um after you finished I started in 2008 and there
拥有那种连接真是太美妙了。但那一直是我康复之旅中非常强大、具有治愈意义的一部分，拥有那些连接绝对是这样的。我很高兴你，你知道，尝试了轮椅篮球，然后那最终为你发生了，因为听起来你得到了你恰好需要的东西，而当时你甚至可能并不真正知道你需要它，它对你来说是具有变革意义的，并且，它听起来太棒了，我很高兴你拥有过那个经历；
were parents on the cohort um I would say that largely there was a more sensitive you know shift to making sure their placements were going to be doable especially because one of the parents was a was a single parent and so you know it really is them or or nobody that's going to be picking those children up but um you know you've really described having to battle many many things but having now been a few decades into being wheelchair user and you know the changes that have happened really probably since the pandemic you know about neurodiversity about inclusivity about disability about inclusion for all of our individual quirks and differences do you think there's differences for being a wheelchair user currently 2023 than there was when you were coming up through the system and
而且当你在谈论你作为助理心理学家的经历，然后你作为培训生的经历，听起来简直太可怕了，还要作为一个父母，你知道——所以我是在你之后不久接受培训的，在你完成之后，我于 2008 年开始，当时同行中确实也有父母，我想说的是，很大程度上，在确保他们的实习是可行的方面，有一个更敏感的转变，尤其是因为其中一位父母是单亲父母，所以，你知道，这真的要么是他们，要么就没有人去接那些孩子，但是，你知道，你确实描述了不得不与许多许多事情作斗争，但现在作为轮椅使用者已经几十年了，并且，你知道，自从大流行以来真正可能发生的变化，关于神经多样性、包容性、残疾、为了我们所有的个别怪癖和差异的包容，你认为在 2023 年当一名轮椅使用者，与你当时在这个系统中成长时，
when you were learning to be disabled yourself? It's really interesting you ask that. And I think when I became a wheelchair user, it was pre the Disability Discrimination Act 1995. But there was already kind of a movement towards that. And I think the Americans with Disabilities Act came out in, I think, 1990. And, you know, that set a template really for the DDA in this country and so there was a real sort of positive movement towards rights for disabled people and anti-discrimination legislation and it was a battle you know to get that in place
以及当你正在学习如何成为一名残疾人时，有什么不同吗？你这么问真的很有意思。我想当我成为一名轮椅使用者时，那是在 1995 年《残疾人歧视法案》（Disability Discrimination Act）出台之前。但当时已经有了一种朝着这个方向发展的运动。而且我认为美国《残疾人法案》（Americans with Disabilities Act）是在 1990 年出台的，你知道，那确实为这个国家的 DDA 设定了一个模板，所以当时确实出现了一场真正积极的运动，朝着残疾人权利和反歧视立法迈进，这是一场斗争，你知道，为了让它落实到位，
and I think there was a period of huge hope after that for disability inclusion and real positivity and growth. And I think, you know, public buildings changed, shopping centres changed, the built environment generally changed, people's access to work changed. You know, you could go to an employer and say, this isn't actually good enough, you know, you can't discriminate against me in this way. And so things had moved on massively. So by the time I was entering clinical training in 2003, things were feeling very, very hopeful and positive. And I felt like I could, you know, I could go in there and say, actually, this isn't good enough, can you do this? And can you make this reasonable adjustment? And can you do that? And I saw things changing over a period of time and improving. And then I don't know what happened around 13, 14 years ago,
而且我认为在那之后有一段时期，人们对残疾包容抱有巨大的希望，充满了真正的积极性和成长。并且我认为，你知道，公共建筑发生了变化，购物中心发生了变化，整体的建筑环境发生了变化，人们获得工作的机会也发生了变化。你知道，你可以去找雇主说，这实际上不够好，你知道，你不能以这种方式歧视我。所以事情已经取得了巨大的进展。因此，当我于 2003 年进入临床培训时，情况感觉非常非常有希望和积极。我觉得我可以，你知道，我可以走进去说，实际上，这还不够好，你能这样做吗？你能做出这个合理的调整吗？你能做到那个吗？我看到事情在一段时间内发生了变化并有所改善。然后我不知道在大约 13、14 年前发生了什么，
but I would say that things have gone massively downhill. I do know what happened 13 or 14 years ago, there was a change of government. And I would say that politically, the will has changed massively. And where you are noticing that maybe there's more understanding of neurodiversity and inclusion since the pandemic, I would say the opposite, actually. I would say that the pandemic highlighted the disposability of disabled people actually in certain quarters, you know, it's coming out in the little bit in the Covid inquiry now. This government were very happy to throw disabled people, older people, sick people under the Covid bus and you know, I was really alarmed at the beginning right at the beginning
但我会说事情已经大大走下坡路了。我的确知道 13 或 14 年前发生了什么，政权更迭了。我会说在政治上，意愿已经发生了巨大的改变。而在你注意到自从大流行以来可能对神经多样性和包容性有了更多理解的地方，我反而会说正好相反。我会说大流行实际上在某些方面突显了残疾人的可抛弃性，你知道，这现在在新冠调查中稍微显露出来了一点。本届政府非常乐意把残疾人、老年人、生病的人扔到新冠的公交车下，你知道，我真的在刚开始时感到震惊，
of the first lockdown I was just preparing to do my teaching session to the second year Leeds trainees on disability and literally we'd locked down a week and a half before I was due to deliver this training and I was having to quickly rejiggle my slides and everything into a format that I could deliver somehow and I didn't even know how online whether that was going to be me doing it live online or sending a presentation it was all so up in the air at that point and while I was prepping my presentation to do that there was literally a debate going on in Parliament about the COVID Act and they were discussing things like if two people turned up in A&E needing a ventilator and one was disabled and one wasn't then obviously the able-bodied one would have to have the ventilator and the
就在第一次封锁开始时，我正准备向利兹的第二年培训生进行关于残疾的教学课程，而实际上我们在我预定进行这次培训的一周半前就封锁了，我不得不迅速重新调整我的幻灯片和一切，变成一种我能以某种方式交付的格式，我甚至不知道该如何在线进行，无论是通过我在线直播还是发送演示文稿，当时一切都悬而未决。而当我正在准备我的演示文稿来做这件事时，议会中实际上正在进行关于《新冠法案》（COVID Act）的辩论，他们讨论的事情比如，如果两个人来到急诊室需要呼吸机，其中一个是残疾人，另一个不是，那么很明显，身体健全的那个人必须使用呼吸机，而
disabled one would have to die and that was literally being discussed in parliament and you know here i am a disabled person very healthy doing very valuable work in the community you know as a psychologist and as a wheelchair basketball coach and also parenting a young person who at that point would have been 18 19 i think um who has a learning disability, cerebral palsy and autism. And hearing that she also would be thrown under the bus now, you know, that was so complicated to get my head around, you know, as a carer of a young person like that. If I get thrown under the bus and, you know, I don't get the ventilator, then who's going to look after her? Well, obviously, my husband would. But he was also clinically vulnerable, because he was on immunosuppressants at the time for asthma and eczema. So he was going to be vulnerable, he wasn't going to get
残疾的那个人就必须死，而这当时正literally（字面意思）在议会中被讨论，你知道，我在这里，一个残疾人，非常健康，在社区中做着非常有价值的工作，你知道，作为一个心理学家和轮椅篮球教练，同时还在抚养一个年轻人，当时她可能 18、19 岁，我想，她患有学习障碍、脑瘫和自闭症。听到她现在也会被扔到公交车下，你知道，作为一个这样年轻人的照顾者，这太难以理解了，你知道。如果我被扔到公交车下，并且，你知道，我没有得到呼吸机，那谁来照顾她？当然，我的丈夫会。但他当时也在临床上属于易感人群，因为他当时因哮喘和湿疹正在服用免疫抑制剂。所以他也是易感人群，他也不会得到
the ventilator either. And who was going to advocate for my daughter and support her through all of that. So we had this whole sort of anxiety around that. And I think more and more, you know, just reading Twitter, I shouldn't read it but at the moment I keep seeing psychologists on there and other people on their disability news service and so on talking about the new moves that the government are making on DWP and benefits and how people who are too sick to work are going to be forced to do work placements to kind of earn their benefits. You know, you've either got to do a work placement or kind of die in the process of trying to get that. And, you know, they're just trying to get everyone back to work, even though many, many people are not able to work.
呼吸机。谁来为我的女儿维权并支持她度过这一切？所以我们周围一直存在着这种焦虑。并且我越来越多地，你知道，只是阅读推特——我不应该读它，但目前我一直看到上面的心理学家和其他人在他们的残疾新闻服务等上面谈论政府对 DWP（就业与养老金部）和福利的新举措，以及那些病得太重而无法工作的人将如何被迫参加工作实习来赚取他们的福利。你知道，你要么必须做一份工作实习，要么在试图获得这个的过程中死去。而且，你知道，他们只是想让每个人都回到工作岗位，尽管许多许多人根本无法工作。
My daughter, unfortunately she she tried doing a work placement as part of a college course and it was so stressful to her with her learning disability and autism but she she stopped sleeping and almost became psychotic with the pressure and we had to pull her out of it um you know and that's the kind of level of you know to look at her she looks like someone who could possibly try a bit of work but actually you know the reality is if if the government you know if the dwp kind of forced her into doing some sort of a workplace and the stress would be too much and i don't think people have enough understanding at those kind of policy making levels of the impact of health conditions,
我女儿，不幸的是，她曾试图作为大学课程的一部分做一份工作实习，对她来说，凭借她的学习障碍和自闭症，这压力太大了，以至于她停止了睡眠，并在压力下几乎变得精神病发作，我们不得不让她退出了，你知道，这就是那种程度的，你知道，光看她，她看起来像是一个可以尝试一点工作的人，但实际上，你知道，现实是，如果政府，你知道，如果 DWP 某种程度上迫使她去做某种工作实习，压力会太大，而且我认为人们在那些决策层面上对健康状况的影响没有足够的理解，
neurodiversity, learning impairments, you know, just the extra stuff that disabled people have to deal with. I mean, just to give you another example, as a family, well, I went to a conference in London a week ago on Friday, and we decided in advance of that that we would make it a family trip to London and have the weekend there. So we did that. I went to my conference on the Friday. We did the lift was out of order and they were hoping it would be back in order by the time we returned because we'd be returning on the opposite platform and we'd need the lift to get over the footbridge. Anyway, Sunday evening came and we were at King's Cross station and we said you know we're here for the assistance people can you get us on the train please and by the way they mentioned about the lift can you check that that's sorted please and they phoned ahead and they said no the lift's still out at
神经多样性、学习障碍，你知道，仅仅是残疾人必须应对的额外事情。我的意思是，再举一个例子，作为一个家庭，嗯，我在一个星期五的上一周去伦敦参加了一个会议，我们在那之前决定把它变成一次去伦敦的家庭旅行并在那里过周末。所以我们照做了。我周五去开会了。我们做了，电梯坏了，他们希望在我们返回时它能修好，因为我们将在相反的站台返回，我们需要电梯来穿过人行天桥。不管怎样，星期天晚上了，我们在国王十字车站（King's Cross station），我们说，你知道，我们是来找协助人员的，请把我们送上火车，顺便说一句，他们提到了电梯的事，请检查一下那个修好了吗？他们提前打了电话，然后说，不，韦克菲尔德的电梯仍然坏着，
Wakefield what you'll probably have to do is either get off at Doncaster and get a taxi well my daughter's a wheelchair user as well as I am so there wasn't going to be a taxi that could take both of us from Doncaster to somewhere in between Wakefield and Huddersfield so we said that would probably be a challenge. And they said the other option is you take the train past Wakefield, you go to Leeds, you get another train, you come back from Leeds to Wakefield and you come in on the correct platform then. Well, that's what we ended up having to do.
你们可能不得不做的是要么在唐卡斯特（Doncaster）下车然后打车——嗯，我女儿也是个轮椅使用者，我同样也是，所以不会有一辆出租车能把我们两个从唐卡斯特带到韦克菲尔德和哈德斯菲尔德之间的某个地方。所以我们说那可能是一个挑战。他们说另一个选择是你们坐过韦克菲尔德的火车，去利兹（Leeds），再换乘另一辆火车，从利兹坐回来到韦克菲尔德，然后你们就能从正确的站台上下来了。嗯，那就是我们最后不得不做的事情。
That added an hour to our journey home. I can see you shaking your head there. It's ridiculous, isn't it? It's just madness, isn't it? it you know it's not all right it's not it's not I mean we plumbed the time we were coming home with the thought that you know I had a full day's clinic supervision clinics on the Monday so arriving home at a time where we could relax and chill and watch a bit of telly and all of that that was all factored in you know to me being able to be up and ready for work the next day and as it was we ended up not getting home till sort of after 10 o'clock at night because we'd had to do this extra hour on on the train um to get in on the right platform and you know some
那给我们的回家之旅增加了一个小时。我可以看到你在那里摇头。太荒谬了，不是吗？简直是疯狂，不是吗？这，你知道，这不对，这不是，这不是——我的意思是，我们计划回家的时间时，考虑到我知道我在周一有一整天的诊所督导诊所——所以在周一可以放松、休息、看一点电视以及所有这些事情的时间到家，这都被考虑进去了，你知道，为了让我能够为第二天的上班养精蓄锐、做好准备。但实际上，我们直到晚上 10 点多才到家，因为我们不得不在火车上多坐这额外的一个小时来从正确的站台进站，你知道，一些
people talk about you know um how services and government and and people just don't recognize the extra time and energy that that sort of thing takes from disabled people and when the government is saying we're going to force disabled people into work through these benefit sanctions what they don't realize is that those are the things we're dealing with an extra hour on your journey imagine if I was commuting from Wakefield to somewhere south of here um every day and having to do that as part of my commute every day you know does that time not matter does it does it not matter that for example then I might not be able to pick my kids up from nursery and get them fed at a sensible time you know the extra energy and effort involved in that is just crazy
人谈论，你知道，服务机构和政府以及人们只是没有认识到残疾人那种事情需要花费的额外时间和精力，当政府说我们要通过这些福利制裁强迫残疾人去工作时，他们没有意识到的是，这些正是我们正在应对的事情：你行程中多出的一个小时。想象一下，如果我每天都要从韦克菲尔德通勤到这里以南的某个地方，并且每天都必须将此作为我通勤的一部分，你知道，这些时间难道不重要吗？难道不重要吗，例如，那我可能无法去幼儿园接我的孩子并在一个合理的时间喂饱他们，你知道，其中涉及的额外精力和努力简直太疯狂了。
yeah yeah and you know I get I'm sorry that my questioning about you know improvements perhaps now seems quite naive but that's been enlightening for me how would you questioning about, you know, improvements perhaps now seems quite naive, but that's been enlightening for me. How would you know? How would you know? Yeah, I guess for me as a non-wheelchair user, what I see is the rise of the ramps. You know, there's been many, many more ramps created. And so I guess that just made me think that it was better you know and that because people are better at advocating and kind of knowing about disability discrimination I hoped
是的，是的，你知道，我明白——我很抱歉我关于“现在可能有所改善”的提问看起来相当天真，但这对我有启迪作用。你怎么会知道呢？你怎么会知道呢？是的，我想对我来说作为一个非轮椅使用者，我看到的是坡道的增加。你知道，创建了更多更多的坡道。所以我想这只会让我觉得情况变得更好了，你知道，并且因为人们更擅长维权并了解残疾歧视，我希望
I was a home carer for a number of years and so I did used to hang around with lots of people with wheelchairs and what I used to find is because I was pushing them people would talk to me rather than the client themselves. And it's like, oh, no, no, no, no. You know, this is the person you want to be speaking to. But since that time, I haven't really spent much time with people in wheelchairs other than grandparents here and there, fleeting moments. So thank you for illuminating my knowledge, updating my knowledge. And, you know, I hope I hope that changes and I hope that anybody listening to this who might well be a wheelchair user themselves who've written written off this
我当过好几年的家庭护理员，所以我经常和很多坐轮椅的人待在一起。我发现的一点是，因为是我在推他们，人们往往会跟我说话，而不是和客户本人交流。当时的感觉就像是：“哦，不，不，不，不。你知道的，这才是你们应该对话的人。”但从那以后，除了偶尔在一些地方和祖父母有短暂的接触外，我其实没有花太多时间与坐轮椅的人相处。所以，谢谢你丰富了我的知识，更新了我的认知。而且，你知道的，我希望这种现象能有所改变，我也希望任何收听这期节目的听众，如果他们自己恰好是轮椅使用者，并且曾认为这种
career for themselves begins to believe that actually with the right tenacity the right determination the right ability and confidence to assert yourself this can happen this is a viable career for you yeah and if anyone was in that position and wanted to reach out to me personally I'm on all the main socials you know I'm on Twitter I'm on LinkedIn I'm on Facebook so you know if anyone was in that position of thinking is this career even viable and how on earth do I do it then you know they could absolutely reach out to me and I'd happily mentor them through the process if needed because we need more you know we need more visibility we need more people with all the diversities in the career because otherwise what we end up with is an act well what we have at the moment
职业对他们来说不可能实现，能够开始相信，实际上只要有足够的韧性、决心、能力和自信去为自己发声，这一切都是有可能的。对你来说，这也是一条可行的职业道路。是的，如果有人正处于这种境地，并想亲自联系我，我在所有主流社交平台上都能找到，你知道的，我有Twitter、LinkedIn和Facebook。所以，如果有人处于那种状态，正想着“这条职业道路真的可行吗？我到底该怎么做？”，那么，你知道的，他们完全可以联系我。如果需要的话，我很乐意在此过程中为他们提供指导，因为我们需要更多——你知道的，我们需要更高的可见度，我们需要更多具备各种多元背景的人加入这个职业，否则，我们最终得到的将会是——好吧，这就是我们目前所拥有的——
is is lots and lots of able-bodied white middle-class women you know a few men um you know a few people from more working class backgrounds well i just say this this able-bodied white middle-class woman is trying to do her bit to make the absolutely absolutely you are and and don't we all you know we all try to make it more inclusive however it is very um you know sort of um i can't think of the word is it homogenic or i can't remember the word now but but kind of um you know, there's not much variety in the profession. There is some, you know, we have people of different races, different colours, different religions, we have people of different backgrounds and origins and class,
有非常非常多健全的白人中产阶级女性，你知道的，还有少数男性，嗯，你知道的，还有少数来自更偏向工人阶级背景的人。好吧，我只想说，这位健全的白人中产阶级女性正在尽自己的一份力，让——完全如此，完全如此，你的确在这么做。而且我们不都是这样吗？你知道的，我们都在努力让它变得更具包容性。然而，它非常……你知道的，某种程度上……嗯，我想不出那个词了，是同质化的吗？我现在记不清那个词了，但有点……你知道的，这个行业里的多样性其实并不多。虽然确实有一些，你知道的，我们有不同种族、不同肤色、不同宗教信仰的人，我们有来自不同背景、起源和阶层的人，
and we have people with disability amongst our number, but probably not enough. And I think, you know, we need to be sort of giving those people a metaphorical leg up, helping to increase the diversity, really, you know, we just need to increase that diversity in the profession, because we're here to help the whole range of people out there. If we don't represent the populations that we're trying to help, then we can't fully understand what they're dealing with. And I'm not saying every psychologist has to understand every aspect of diversity,
我们的群体中也有残疾人，但可能还不够。而且我认为，你知道的，我们应该给这些人提供某种形式的“隐形助力”，真正地去帮助提升多样性，你知道的，我们就是需要提升这个职业中的多样性，因为我们来到这里的目的是为了帮助形形色色的大众。如果我们不能代表我们试图去帮助的那些群体，那么我们就无法完全理解他们正在面对的事情。我并不是说每个心理学家都必须理解多样性的方方面面，
but we do need to be curious about it. And I don't think there's any problem with, you know, a white psychologist helping someone from, you know, a Muslim community or a black community. I think, you know, as long as we stay open and curious and, you know, ask, you know, am I getting this? Am I understanding it right? You know, you put one idea to me and I said, well, actually, that's not my experience. My experience is different to that. You didn't put it in an offensive way. You were just curious. And
但我们确实需要对此保持好奇心。而且我认为这没有任何问题，你知道的，一个白人心理学家去帮助一个来自——你知道的——穆斯林社区或黑人社区的人。我认为，你知道的，只要我们保持开放和好奇，并且，你知道的，去问问：“我真的理解了吗？我这样理解对吗？”你知道的，你之前向我提出过一个观点，而我说：“嗯，其实，那并不是我的经历。我的经历和你的不同。”你提出时并没有带任何冒犯的意味，你只是觉得好奇。而
that's what we can model, isn't it? We can model that curiosity. But I think as a profession, we don't really represent the communities that we're trying to help fully enough yet. And I think there are, of diversity, even the LGBTQ communities, you know, I don't think they're fully represented within our numbers in the profession yet. And I think, you know, for people who want specific support around certain issues of difference and diversity, then it can can be really really helpful if they can find someone with those experiences who can then you know sort of help them to see a way forward yeah absolutely and as a very recent on the ground update someone I worked with when I was in
这正是我们可以树立的榜样，不是吗？我们可以树立那种好奇心的榜样。但我认为，作为一个职业群体，我们目前还未能充分代表我们试图去帮助的那些社区。而且我认为，在多样性方面，甚至包括LGBTQ群体，你知道的，我认为他们在我们这个职业的从业人员中还没有得到充分的代表。并且我认为，你知道的，对于那些想要针对特定差异和多样性议题获得具体支持的人来说，如果他们能找到具有这些经历的人，那将会非常非常有帮助。然后这些人就可以，你知道的，某种程度上帮助他们看到一条前进的道路。是的，完全同意。就在不久前，在实际工作中，我在
Birmingham had recently shared on Facebook that when she was training in Birmingham she'd been the only person of colour on the cohort and then when she was teaching this week looking out a sea of faces of people from different diversities different backgrounds she said just was so lovely to see how that change has been happening. And I've definitely seen and been experienced to more people from certainly neurodiversity kind of coming through training. And I know there are people from the LGBTQ community who are qualified psychologists. But I think it's potentially more difficult to be out there yeah in your role and in your job I've been trying to get someone to come on the podcast
伯明翰工作时认识的一个人最近在Facebook上分享说，当她在伯明翰接受培训时，她是同批学员中唯一的有色人种。然而，当她本周去授课时，放眼望去是一张张来自不同多样性背景的面孔，她说，看到这种改变正在发生，真的是太美妙了。我确实也看到并体验到，有更多背景的人——尤其是神经多样性群体——开始参与到培训中来。而且我知道，LGBTQ群体中也有获得资质的心理学家。但我认为，要在你的角色和工作中公开这一点，可能，潜在地会更加困难。我一直试图邀请某位
who is comfortable kind of talking about some of that and their experiences but I haven't yet managed that so if you know of anyone or if anyone listening knows of any qualified psychologists from the lgbtq i might have added an extra word i have a suggestion for you there yeah i have a suggestion for you there great yeah perfect yeah um but yeah you know it's it's being able to see what we want to be isn't it um that can be so inspiring and transformational absolutely absolutely yeah yeah so when did you first see what you wanted to be which was an author as well yeah um I think I think even as early as when I was recovering in hospital from my illness people kept saying to me oh you
乐于谈论其中一部分内容及其经历的人来参加播客，但我目前还没能做到这一点。所以，如果你认识这样的人，或者任何听众认识任何来自LGBTQ群体的合格心理学家——我是不是多加了一个词？我这里有个建议给你。对，我这里有个建议给你。太棒了，对，完美，对。但是，是的，你知道的，能够看到我们想要成为什么样的人，难道不是吗……那种感觉可以如此鼓舞人心且具有变革意义。完全如此，完全如此，对，对。那么，你是什么时候第一次看到自己想成为什么样的人——也就是成为一名作家呢？是的，嗯，
should write a book about this and I was kind of thinking well I haven't really got much to write yet and I don't I didn't think anyone very interested in that aspect of it so I suppose there was always the seed of an idea there that maybe there was something in my story and I suppose as my story then unfolded over the decades since, you know, the sort of sports story that kind of fleshes it out a bit. Maybe there's stuff in that to kind of add in. But really my psychology journey. And then probably over the last sort of, I don't know, half a dozen years or so, we've had some very lively Facebook communities where psychologists have really got together. And over the last few, several years, really, we've had some very vibrant Facebook groups where psychologists have got together and shared ideas. And, you know, there's been many of us doing all different sorts of things, different sorts of work, particularly in the private practice field.
我想，甚至早在我在医院从病情中康复的时候，人们就不停地对我说：“哦，你应该把这段经历写成一本书。”我当时就在想，嗯，其实我还没什么好写的，而且我觉得别人可能对这其中的那部分内容不会太感兴趣。所以我想，那颗想法的种子其实一直都在那里，也许我的故事里确实有些东西可写。而且我想，随着我的故事在之后的几十年里逐渐展开，你知道的，那种运动经历让它变得更加血肉丰满了一些。也许其中确实有一些内容可以加进去。但真正让我走上心理学之旅的，大概是在过去这——我不知道，大约六七年的时间里，我们拥有了一些非常活跃的Facebook社群，心理学家们真正在那里聚到了一起。而在过去的几年、好几年里，说实话，我们拥有了一些非常充满活力的Facebook群组，心理学家们在那里聚在一起分享想法。而且，你知道的，我们当中有许多人都在做着各种各样不同的事情、不同种类的工作，特别是在私人执业领域。
The psychologist group for private practice is very lively and has many, many very capable, competent, inspiring people in it. And, you know, you start to see, you know, I saw that you'd written a book about grief and then about aspiring psychologists. And then there was Michaela Thomas had written her couples therapy book. And I'm trying to think who else. Various people had written books. And it started to feel like, actually, you know, I've got quite a lot of knowledge now I've been a psychologist for nearly 20 years I've been working in the mental health field for well over 20 years now going on for 30 years so you know I started to think that maybe I have some stuff to share here and it happened almost by accident that I received an email from the Association for Clinical Psychologists from Sarah Swan, who had just written a book on coping with breast cancer from the perspective of someone who'd lived the journey, but that this could be a series of books. You know, psychologists are
私人执业心理学家群组非常活跃，里面有许多许多非常有能力、非常称职、非常鼓舞人心的人。而且，你知道的，你开始看到——你知道的，我看到你写了一本关于悲伤的书，然后是关于有志成为心理学家的书。接着米凯拉·托马斯（Michaela Thomas）也写了她的伴侣治疗书。我在想还有谁。各种各样的人都写过书。并且这开始让我觉得，实际上，你知道的，我已经有了相当多的知识。我已经当了将近20年的心理学家，我在心理健康领域工作的时间也远远超过了20年，甚至快要接近30年了。所以，你知道的，我开始觉得，也许我这里也有一些东西可以拿出来分享。而这件事发生得几乎就像是个意外。我收到了临床心理学家协会（Association for Clinical Psychologists）萨拉·斯旺（Sarah Swan）发来的一封电子邮件。她刚刚从一个亲历者的角度，写了一本关于如何应对乳腺癌的书，但她认为这可以成为一系列书籍。你知道的，心理学家也是
human too, they live experiences, they have, they all, you know, we've all got stuff to bring, we all experience the things that everyone experiences in life. And so they sent out an email saying, you know, has anyone else got a story in them about this? And I responded to that email, despite my imposter syndrome popping up its naughty head and saying, no, no, no, no, no, you couldn't possibly. I actually thought, no, actually, yes, I could. And I quietened my imposter and pinged an email straight back and said, I could do coping with trauma. I've lived it, it's my area of expertise work-wise and I have that book in me, I just need to put it down on paper and I ended up doing a book proposal, being accepted and spending three years writing Cop coping with trauma, which has a fair amount of self-disclosure about
人，他们也有生活经历，他们都有，你知道的，我们每个人都有东西可以贡献，我们每个人都会经历生活中每个人都会经历的事情。因此他们发了一封电子邮件问：“你知道的，还有谁的肚子里也装着这样一个故事吗？”我回复了那封电子邮件，尽管我的冒 impostor syndrome（冒名顶替综合征）探出了它淘气的脑袋对我说：“不，不，不，不，不，你绝对不可能做到。”但我实际上想的是：“不，其实，是的，我能行。”我安抚好了我的“冒名顶替综合征”，直接回了一封邮件说：“我可以写《应对创伤》（Coping with Trauma）。我亲身经历过，这是我专业工作领域的专长，我肚子里确实有这样一本书，我只需要把它写到纸上就行了。”最终我提交了一份图书提案，获得通过并花了三年时间写成了《应对创伤》这本书。书中包含了相当多的自我披露，关于
my own trauma journey, probably, to be fair, heavily filtered in places, you know, just to protect the innocent, or the not so innocent. But yeah, then applying how I got through that journey, and the lessons that I've learned through being a psychologist and applying those lessons retrospectively I suppose to my journey and thinking about you know how did I cope actually in many ways I coped using a sort of ACT model but ACT hadn't really been invented then that's acceptance and commitment therapy which was kind of written in, I suppose, the 90s and early 2000s. It became very popular. Steve Hayes, Russ Harris, various other names, Robin Walsh is very big in the ACT community. So, yeah, I think I was kind of applying some of those lessons, not always properly, but, you know, some of those things of, okay,
我自己的创伤之旅。说实话，为了保护无辜者（或者那些没那么无辜的人），可能在某些地方经过了大量筛选。但随后，我运用自己是如何度过那段旅程的方法，以及我作为一名心理学家所学到的教训，并将这些教训追溯性地应用到我自己的旅程中。我思考着，你知道的，当年我究竟是怎么应对的？其实在很多方面，我都是用一种ACT（接纳承诺疗法）模型来应对的，但当时ACT其实还没被发明出来。那是接纳承诺疗法，大概是在90年代和2000年代初被写出来的。它变得非常受欢迎。史蒂夫·海斯（Steve Hayes）、拉斯·哈里斯（Russ Harris），还有其他各种名字，罗宾·沃许（Robin Walsh）在ACT社群里非常有名。所以，是的，我想我当时其实是在应用其中的一些教训，虽然并不总是那么标准，但你知道的，其中包含了一些这样的原则：“好吧，
so I'm disabled now, can't do much about that. So that's the acceptance part. But then, you know, what matters? What do I want to do? How am I going to live my life now? I'm only 19. What am I going to do with my time? You know, I could just give up and live on benefits or I could live my life. How am I going to do that? And I found my way into various sporting endeavours and then back into education. And I found my people through academia and sport. And yeah, the rest is history. It's all in the book.
我现在残疾了，对此我也无可奈何。所以这就是接纳的部分。”但接下来，你知道的，“什么才是重要的？我想做什么？我接下来要怎么生活？我才19岁，我要怎么利用我的时间？你知道的，我可以选择放弃，靠救济金生活，或者我可以好好过我的人生。我该怎么做？”我通过各种体育运动找到了自己的方向，然后重新回到了教育界。我在学术界和体育界找到了属于我的人群。是的，剩下的就是历史了。全都在书里呢。
Oh, so the first thing that struck me was your really wonderfully heartfelt dedication at the start of the book to your colleague and friend who died. She was so young. She died from leukemia. And I think it's really lovely that you've dedicated it to her. Yeah, I mean, she didn't work in psychology. She was a friend who I'd met through wheelchair basketball, in fact. And yeah, it wasn't actually in the end the leukaemia that killed her. It was the treatment. She'd actually gone into remission from the leukaemia after two bone marrow transplants but it was the second bone marrow transplant and what that took out of her that ultimately killed her so she died of graft versus host disease or in fact she actually died of you know chest infection sepsis kind of um situation as a result but yeah she was such a close friend she was so inspiring and and supportive and she so wanted me to get this book written and finished and you know she was so supportive with that but she just didn't make it she died earlier this summer and she just didn't make it to see the book published so yeah yeah I'm so sorry for your
哦，所以给我留下的第一深刻印象，是你在书的开头为那位不幸离世的同事兼朋友写下的那段非常精彩、真挚的献词。她太年轻了。她死于白血病。而且我觉得你把这本书献给她，真的是一件非常美好的事情。是的，我的意思是，她并不是从事心理学工作的。事实上，她是我通过轮椅篮球结识的一位朋友。而且，是的，最终夺去她生命的其实并不是白血病，而是治疗过程。通过两次骨髓移植，她的白血病其实已经达到缓解了，但正是第二次骨髓移植以及那对她身体的消耗最终杀死了她。所以她死于移植物抗宿主病，或者实际上，她死于作为结果的，你知道的，胸部感染、败血症之类的情况。但是，是的，她是一位如此亲密的朋友，她是如此鼓舞人心、给予我支持，并且她非常渴望我能把这本书写完。你知道的，她在这方面给予了极大的支持，但她最终没能挺过去。她在今年夏天早些时候去世了，没能看到这本书出版。所以，是的，是的，对于你的
loss and for the the loss of those who loved her as well but you know I was starting to read the book um when I was on a train and I was like oh that's really touching really touching yeah um I loved that the so I use a fair amount of self-disclosure in what I do either in my books or in the podcast because I know from my own experience when you've got a case study in mind it helps you so much and I love that this is actually your book is part of a series of psychologists who have those personal case studies but that you also use case studies in your book as well to kind of illuminate um and allow people to really get that tangible feel so that was something I really liked and you know it feels like um for me trauma felt proper you know big scary like I needed to be a
失去，以及那些爱她的人所遭受的失去，我感到非常难过。但是，你知道的，我当时正在火车上读这本书，我当时想：“哦，这真的好感人，真的好感人。”是的，嗯，我喜欢这种……所以我会在我的工作中使用相当多的自我披露，无论是在我的书里还是在播客里，因为根据我自己的经验我知道，当你心里有一个具体的案例研究时，它会对你产生巨大的帮助。并且我喜欢的是，实际上你的这本书是一系列由拥有这些个人案例研究的心理学家所著书籍的一部分，但你在书中也使用了案例研究，以此来阐明
proper human um a very established psychologist to to even consider getting to grips with it and I wish I'd picked up books on trauma before I did um you know I really believe that as a society we should be trauma informed and I think your book would be an excellent place to start for anybody who may be like me is thinking oh that's much further down my career because what we know and what you illuminate us with the book as well is that so much of what we might see as physical health is actually kind of complications from trauma and so much about what we see about so many mental health presentations might well have started with trauma um yeah and it might be as you as you talk about in your book it might be type one trauma it might be type true trauma so it might
并让人们真正获得那种切实的感受，所以这是我非常喜欢的一点。而且，你知道的，感觉就像是……对我来说，创伤曾经显得那么正统，你知道的，既重大又可怕，让我觉得我必须是一个
be something that's been around all someone's life or it might be you know a very big crater a very big bump in the road um that's caused that but you know we've got to know and help people de-shame themselves. It's not their fault. And I think that's what your book really does really well. So well done to you. Oh, thank you. Thank you. It's really good to get feedback. Obviously, it's very early days because it's not. Well, as we're speaking now, it's not actually quite out. By the time this goes out it will be out in the public domain obviously its publication date is early December so we're recording this
正经的人、一个非常资深的心理学家，才配去考虑着手处理它。我真希望自己在之前就已经读过关于创伤的书籍……你知道的，我坚信作为一个社会，我们应该具备创伤知情意识（trauma-informed），并且我认为对于任何可能像我一样认为“那是我职业生涯还要很久以后才会涉及的事”的人来说，你的书会是一个极佳的起点。因为我们所知道的，以及你在书中向我们阐明的，是我们在身体健康方面看到的许多问题，实际上往往是创伤带来的并发症；而我们在许多心理健康表现中所看到的现象，很大程度上也可能始于创伤。
slightly before that so I haven't I haven't had huge numbers of people read it and feedback yet so that's obviously you know every little bit of feedback that I get that suggests I hit the mark is really reassuring. Yeah, so thank you for that. Yeah. So one of the things I think is that, you know, one of my audiences is people who are experiencing the after effects of trauma themselves, and, you know, the sort of self help, helping them to maybe start that journey towards healing themselves. But the other major audience I see is, as you said, people who are at the beginning of maybe their mental health professional journey, who maybe think, oh, trauma sounds big and scary. But having it broken down into a way that, you know, there's all that psycho education, as we call it at the beginning part of the book. You know, what is trauma? How does it impact us? What do we typically see clinically?
是的，而且正如你在书中所讨论的，它可能是I型创伤，也可能是II型创伤。所以它可能
And then kind of all the self-help, the strategies that I've used and that I've learned over the course of my career to help people start that healing journey. You know, exercises that you can do, things that you can do to really help manage. And for someone, when I was an assistant psychologist at the beginning of my journey, and I was thrown into a room with a person who had problems, and I didn't really know what I was supposed to do with them. And so you'd have a conversation with them and you'd maybe validate what they were saying but you know having some actual things to do in the room and some actual things to say to them that were like well this is kind of normal for trauma you know it sounds like you've been
是伴随一个人一生的某种东西，也可能是，你知道的，生活中的一个巨大裂痕、一块巨大的绊脚石，从而导致了这一切。但你知道的，我们需要去了解并帮助人们消除对创伤的羞耻感。这不是他们的错。我认为这正是你的书做得非常出色的地方。所以，为你点赞。哦，谢谢你，谢谢你。能听到反馈真的很好。显然，现在还处于非常早期的阶段，因为它还没——好吧，在我们现在对话的时候，它其实还没有正式出版。等这期节目播出时，它显然就会进入公众视野了。因为它的出版日期是在12月初，所以我们录制这个节目的时间
through some stuff and this is what we expect to see what you're telling me is what we expect to see and this is something you can do about it I would have so valued a book that did that for me way back when I was at that early part of my career so I think you know your audience of aspiring psychologists and many many other I don't know trainee counsellors trainee mental health nurses even educators you know people in all sorts of different domains of life could really benefit from understanding what trauma is and having some ideas of things you can help people with just at that sort of almost self-help sort of level and that's that's where this book's targeted really yeah and I echo some of that I think think earlier in my career, it was like, gosh, you've been through so much, you know.
比那要稍微早一点。因此，我还没有看到大量的人阅读并给我反馈，所以很显然，你知道的，我收到的每一个表明我达到了预期的反馈，都让我感到无比欣慰。是的，所以谢谢你。是的。所以，我认为其中一件事是，你知道的，我的受众之一是那些正在亲历创伤后遗症的人，并且，你知道的，也就是自助类的受众，帮助他们或许能够开始那段自我治愈的旅程。但我看到的另一个主要受众，正如你所说的那样，是那些可能正处于心理健康专业人士职业生涯起点的人。他们可能会觉得：“哦，创伤听起来好大、好可怕。”但是，如果把它拆解开来，用一种方式呈现——你知道的，就像书的开头部分那样，包含了我们所称的心理教育（psychoeducation）。你知道的，什么是创伤？它对我们有什么影响？我们在临床上通常会看到什么？
You can't really change that. I can't really alter that. And I really liked something I've not actually thought about but makes a lot of sense was one of my children's favourite books was We're Going on a Bear Hunt. And you mentioned that in your book, you know, and people can want to avoid their distress avoid that yeah because understandably but you know you you really beautifully talk about you know not going around it not going past it oh and then they realize oh no we're gonna have to go through it but what we do in trauma treatment is we do that stabilization we help them know that it's going to be okay that it's it's safe
然后是所有的自助内容，也就是我用来帮助人们开始那段治愈之旅的策略，以及我在职业生涯中积累的经验。你知道的，你可以做的练习，那些真正有助于进行自我调节的事情。对于某个人来说，当我还处于职业生涯起点的助理心理学家时，我被扔进了一个房间里，面对着一个有着各种问题的人，而我其实并不知道自己应该拿他们怎么办。所以你会和他们对话，你可能会认可他们所说的话，但是，你知道的，如果在房间里有一些实际可做的事情，以及一些真正可以对他们说的话，比如：“嗯，对于创伤来说，这其实是很正常的。你知道的，听起来你经历了一些事情，而这就是我们预料中会出现的情况。你告诉我的一切都是我们预期会看到的，而且关于这一点，你是有事情可以做的。”如果当年我在职业生涯的那个早期阶段，能有一本这样做的书，我会觉得它无比珍贵。所以我想，你知道的，你们的受众——那些有志成为心理学家的人，以及许多许多其他人——我不知道，比如实习咨询师、实习精神科护士，甚至教育工作者，你知道的，生活在各个不同领域的人，真的都可以通过理解什么是创伤，并在那种几乎是自助的层面上掌握一些可以用来帮助别人的方法而受益匪浅。而这正是这本书真正瞄准的目标受众，是的。而且我对此深有同感，我认为在我的职业生涯早期，那种感觉就像是：“天哪，你经历了这么多，你知道的，
to do that and that it's only ever going to be done in a manageable humane way and i think what i've experienced i'm sure what you have is sometimes repairing some of the damage that's been done by less sensitive hands um yeah from previous therapists is is that you have to begin to get them to trust you to know that you know yeah what they can you know cope with and you're not going to plunge them into despair so that you know people say you know I know it often gets better before it gets worse and they might come along thinking that the first session I'm just going to totally take them to bits and that's just not ethical that doesn't happen it should always feel like it so I do personal training as well if my personal trainer had stacked out my weights to begin with it would have damaged me you know like wouldn't I wouldn't
你真的没法改变这一点。我真的无法改变它。”我非常喜欢的一个观点——我以前其实没想过，但现在觉得非常有道理——是我其中一个孩子最喜欢的书是《我们要去捉狗熊》（We're Going on a Bear Hunt）。你在书里也提到了这一点，你知道的，人们会想要逃避他们的痛苦，逃避那个——是的，这是可以理解的。但是，你知道的，你非常精彩地谈到了：不要绕过它，不要从旁边走过去——哦，然后他们意识到：“哦，不，我们必须穿过它。”但在创伤治疗中，我们所做的是进行稳定化处理。我们帮助他们知道这一切都会没事的，这样做是
have come back and so I think we need to do make sure we do I know you do do this anyway yeah yeah we need to allow the patient allow the client the human to grow in their confidence of us and and in their ability to tolerate and manage their own thoughts feelings and their distress of course absolutely absolutely I think you know that idea of you can't go over it, you can't go under it. Oh, no, you've got to go through it. That is true of trauma therapy, you do need to go back and have a proper look at what happened. But you don't just do it from the off, you put things in place. And I think one of the things that my book will do is it will give people some of that what we in for example EMDR for trauma therapy we would talk about the preparation phase and the stabilization phase wouldn't we and I think my book kind of addresses a lot of the stuff that goes on in that before we get into the trauma how are we going to manage ourselves and contain ourselves and how are we going to manage ourselves and contain ourselves? And how are we going to, you know, stay in the moment, stay conscious, stay, you know, in the room when, you know, the overwhelming trauma might cause us to dissociate, to cut off from reality, to destabilise, to decompensate. So, yeah, I think that's all really, really important, isn't it? And I think, you know, for people coming into working with trauma, having some skills to be able to do that and to recognise what's happening,
安全的，并且这永远只会以一种可控的、有人情味的方式进行。而且我想我所经历过的——我相信你也是——有时需要修复由前任治疗师不够细腻的手法所造成的伤害。是的，你需要让他们开始信任你，让他们知道，你知道的，他们能够应付什么，而你不会把他们推向绝望的深渊。所以，你知道的，人们会说：“我知道情况往往会先变糟再变好。”他们可能会带着这种想法来，以为在第一次会谈中我会彻底把他们拆散。但那是不道德的，那不会发生。它应该永远让人感觉——我也做私人健身训练，如果我的私人教练在一开始就把我的负荷直接拉满，那就会伤害到我，你知道的，就像我不会再
even if the patient is becoming or the client is becoming overwhelmed and out of I talk about the window of tolerance, which comes from Dan Siegel's work, you know, that zone where you can actually do some useful therapy and processing and thinking um where you're not hyper aroused and in total fight flight panic mode but not so hypo aroused that you're almost asleep and catatonic as well so it's keeping you in that window where you can actually do the work so yeah my main intervention where i start with everybody is a window of tolerance and it's so illuminating you can see people going oh oh yeah I spent all my time up there all my time down there but I think what we forget about trauma and what clients forget is that there can be post-traumatic growth and I've worn this necklace um purposely today you can't really see on here
回去了。所以我想我们需要确保——我知道你本来也会这么做，是的，是的——我们需要允许患者、允许客户、允许这个人对我们建立信心，并培养他们容忍和管理自己想法、感受以及痛苦的能力。当然，完全如此，完全如此。我认为，你知道的，“你不能从上面过去，你不能从下面过去。哦，不，你必须穿过它”这个观点，对于创伤治疗来说是千真万确的。你确实需要回头去好好审视一下发生了什么。但你不能一上来就这么做，你得先把一些东西落实到位。并且我认为我的书能做到的事情之一，就是为人们提供一些——比如我们在针对创伤的EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法）中会谈到的准备阶段和稳定化阶段，不是吗？我认为我的书在某种程度上探讨了许多在进入创伤核心之前发生的事情：我们要如何管理自己、克制自己？我们要如何管理自己并保持定力？我们要当如何，你知道的，保持当下、保持清醒、保持——你知道的，留在房间里，而此时排山倒海般的创伤可能会导致我们解离（dissociate）、与现实切断联系、失去稳定性、甚至代偿失调？所以，是的，我认为所有这些都非常非常重要，不是吗？并且我认为，你知道的，对于那些开始接触创伤工作的人来说，具备一些能够做到这一点的技能，并能够识别正在发生的事情，
but um perhaps I'll put a close-up photo of it it was actually a whole other issue but it was a gift from a client I'd been seeing for some trauma work and what it is is it's a piece of Clarice Cliff pottery that got broken that has been made into a beautiful piece of jewellery so the client wanted to kind of help me know in tangible ways actually something beautiful can come from trauma and you know you can absolutely get post-traumatic growth um and you can kind of polish up the jagged edges so that they're smooth so that they that they don't feel so spiky and so that they're easier to look at and so I love that analogy yeah it's just the best work in the world isn't it working with people with trauma because you get to meet them in the most
即使患者或客户变得不知所措、超出了——我谈论过“耐受窗”（window of tolerance）的概念，这源自丹·西格尔（Dan Siegel）的研究，你知道的，那个你可以真正进行一些有用的治疗、加工和思考的区域，在那里你不会处于过度觉醒（hyper aroused）状态、陷入彻底的战斗逃跑恐慌模式，但也不会处于过度麻木（hypo aroused）状态、几乎要睡着或陷入紧张症状态。所以，就是要把你保持在那个能够真正开展工作的窗口里。所以，是的，我开始接触每个人的主要干预手段都是“耐受窗”，而且它真的太有启发性了。你可以看到人们露出恍然大悟的表情：“哦！哦，是的！我所有的时间都花在上面那个区域，或者所有的时间都花在下面那个区域了。”但我认为我们对创伤所遗忘的，以及客户们所遗忘的，是创伤后其实可以有成长。我今天特意戴了这条项链，
vulnerable states and then you get to see where they get to and they oh it's just wonderful I just love it yeah likewise and I think you know my thesis was about post-traumatic growth, you know, on my doctorate. And it was something that resonated with me. I heard something in one of the teaching sessions on the doctorate about post-traumatic growth. And it struck a chord with me and I thought I need to go and at my life and thinking, yeah, I've definitely, I can definitely relate to the idea of post-traumatic growth, you know, both through my sport and my education and my career. I definitely have taken something really, really dramatic and traumatic, and I have used it as a platform for growth. And, you know, I'm still growing from it now you know and this book is another example of how i'm growing from that and your little analogy there with your necklace that made me think of the japanese art of kintsugi which um you know is where they take a broken
虽然在这里可能看不太清楚，但也许我会发一张它的特写照片。这其实是另一个完全不同的话题，但它是我的一位客户送给我的礼物。我曾为她做过一些创伤治疗工作。这是一件原本碎掉的克里斯·克利夫（Clarice Cliff）陶器，被重新制作成了一件美丽的珠宝。所以那位客户想要用这种切实的方式让我知道：实际上，美丽的事情确实可以从创伤中诞生。而且你知道的，你绝对可以获得创伤后成长，并且你可以打磨掉那些锯齿状的边缘，让它们变得平滑，这样它们就不会显得那么扎手，看起来也会更容易让人接受。所以我非常喜欢这个比喻。是的，这简直是世界上最好的工作，不是吗？与经历过创伤的人一起工作，因为你有机会在他们最脆弱的状态下遇见他们，然后你看着他们走到他们能抵达的地方，哦，这简直太美妙了，我太爱了。是的，我也是。并且我认为，你知道的，我的博士论文研究的就是创伤后成长。这是我在攻读博士学位期间产生共鸣的一个课题。我在博士课程的其中一个教学环节中听到了关于创伤后成长的内容，它触动了我的心弦，我当时就在想，我需要去审视自己的生活并思考：“是的，我绝对能够理解创伤后成长的概念，无论是通过我的体育运动、我的教育还是我的职业生涯。”我确实把一些非常戏剧化、非常具创伤性的事情，拿来当作了成长的平台。而且，你知道的，直到现在我仍在从中成长，
vessel of some sort and they repair it with gold and you know so you have this um pot that may have just been an earthenware pot for example and it's been dropped and you take all the pieces and you glue it back together and then you mark all the seams with with gold with liquid gold and you know you create something of beauty from something that's been broken and i think that is what you know that is my hopeful message for everybody you know however broken you've been there is hope that you can repair and you could even make something better from the pieces when you put them back together. What an absolutely wonderful note to end on that's so powerful could you tell us more about your social media links where where people can find and connect to you if they'd like to yes absolutely so uh my business name is catalyst
并且这本书就是我如何从中成长的另一个例子。你刚才关于项链的那个小比喻，让我想到了日本的“金缮”（kintsugi）艺术。你知道的，那是他们把某种破碎的器皿用金子修复的技术。所以你会有一个——比如原本可能只是个陶土罐子的东西，它被摔碎了，然后你把所有的碎片收集起来，用胶水把它们重新粘合在一起，接着用金漆——用液态金勾勒出所有的接缝。你知道的，你从破碎的东西中创造出了美丽的事物。我认为这就是，你知道的，我带给所有人的充满希望的信息：无论你曾多么破碎，都依然有希望能够修复，甚至能把这些碎片重新拼凑起来，创造出比以前更好的东西。这是一个多么完美的结束语啊，真的是太有力量了。能跟我们多聊聊你的社交媒体链接吗？如果人们想找到你并与你建立联系，可以去哪里找呢？好的，没问题。所以，嗯，我的公司名称是“催化剂临床心理学”（Catalyst Clinical Psychology），所以在Facebook和Twitter上，我想如果你搜索 @catalyst_clin_psi，就能找到我。但我认为你也可以通过我的名字找到我。如果你输入“伊冯·沃夫特博士”（Dr Yvonne Waft），我想你会找到我的商业Facebook页面、商业Twitter、领英（LinkedIn），而且我最近也在尝试Instagram。我从来都不是Instagram的超级粉丝，但我刚刚重新注册了账号，开始尝试使用它。我想我在那里的账号是 @WaffDevon，就是 W-A-F-F-D-E-V-O-N。太棒了，是的。我会确保从你那里拿到所有这些链接，它们会显示在YouTube上观看视频的观众的屏幕上，并且我会确保在任何在mp3上收听节目的听众的节目简介里，以及我的任何电子邮件中，都有你的详细信息。它们也会出现在节目简介里，其中会有一个链接，教大家如何买到
clinical psychology and so on i think facebook and twitter i think if you do at catalyst clin psi you will find me but i think you can also find me by my name so if you put Dr Yvonne Waft in I think you'll find my business Facebook page my business Twitter my LinkedIn and I'm also just dabbling with Instagram I've never been a big fan of Instagram but I've just kind of got back in there and started trying to use that and I think I'm Woff Devon on there at Woff Devon um lovely yeah I will make sure that I get all those links from you they'll be on screen for anyone watching on YouTube and I will make sure that in the show notes for anyone listening on mp3 and on any of my emails that that your details are there they will also be in the show notes a link for how you can get your hands on a copy of
伊冯博士的新书——那本全新的“书宝宝”。当我出版第一本书的时候，我的一位朋友曾把它比作一只鸟，并对我说：“愿它为你高飞，愿它触及那些需要它的人，愿你在看着它飞翔时为它感到无比骄傲。”我真的非常非常喜欢这个比喻，所以我也想把它分享并送给你。但是，你知道的，《应对创伤》现在已经上市了，我强烈推荐它。非常感谢你抽出时间，谢谢你向我提出制作这期播客的想法。并且，是的，如果未来有什么我可以帮忙的，或者如果你对未来的播客节目有任何新的想法，请务必让我知道。这太棒了。非常感谢邀请我来参加节目。这真的太有趣了。
Dr Yvonne's new book brand new book baby and when I first published my first book a friend of mine likened it to a bird and said you know may it really soar high for you may it reach the people it needs to and may you be really proud of it as you watch it um and I really really love that so I wanted to just share that extend that to you as well but um you know coping with trauma it's available now and I absolutely recommend it thank you so much for your time thank you for pitching this idea of a podcast to me um and yeah please do let me know if there's anything I can help with in future if you've got any future ideas for podcast episodes as well. That's fabulous. Thank you so much for having me on. This has been so much fun.
能有这样一个机会谈论我自己以及我的所作所为，感觉实在是太棒了。这并不是我经常做的事情。我通常都在谈论别人以及他们正在挣扎的事情。难得能借此机会谈谈我自己，感觉真好。好的，非常感谢。与伊冯博士对话并听到更多关于她的故事，是一件多么令人愉快的事啊。我希望你觉得这期节目很有趣。如果你想去看看她的新书——现已上市，请务必查看这篇贴文的说明、节目简介或我社交媒体上的任何链接，你将能够亲自买到一本。如果你在YouTube上观看，你很可能会看到伊冯博士在残奥会时期的照片，还有
It's just so great to have an opportunity to talk about me and what I do. It's not something I do very often. I'm often talking about other people and what they're struggling with. It's lovely to talk about me for a change. Well, thank you very much much how incredibly lovely to speak with dr yvonne and to hear more about her story i hope you found it interesting if you would like to check out her new book which is available now please do check out the description with this post or the show notes or any of the links on my socials and you'll be able to grab a copy of it yourself there. If you're watching on YouTube you might well have caught some photos of Dr. Ravon in her Paralympian days and also
她最近打篮球时的照片。你甚至可能看到了一小段视频，里面是她收到来自出版商的书籍包裹，并生平第一次将那本书拿在手里，那真是一个极其神奇的时刻。如果你有一天也去出版一本书，我希望那会是一本让你尽情引以为豪的书。所以，请告诉我，你希望为即将推出的播客节目制作什么内容。向我推销你的想法吧。绝对的，请务必联系我——我是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent），几乎在所有社交平台上都能找到我。如果会员服务适合你，能帮助你推进在心理学职业生涯中取得进展的目标，请务必去了解一下。我期待着在下一期播客节目中与大家见面，
more recently as she's been playing basketball you may even have caught the little video where she received a package of books from her publisher and she held a copy of that book in her hands for the very first time, which is an utterly magical moment. And if you ever go on to publish a book, I hope it's one that you absolutely revel in. So let me know what content you would like producing for podcast episodes that are coming up. Pitch me your idea. Absolutely. Please do come and get in contact with me, Dr. Marianne Trent, pretty much everywhere on socials. And if the membership would be right for you in advancing your goals for progressing your career in psychology, please do check that out. I will look forward to coming along with the next episode of the podcast
节目将于周一早上6点准时上线。非常感谢大家，照顾好自己，我们很快再见。拜拜！如果你正打算成为一名心理学家……谢谢你。我叫贾娜（Jana），是一名实习心理福祉从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现书中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。成为临床心理学家竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到十分惊奇，而且通往这个职业并没有唯一完美的标准答案。这让我充满了信心，让我觉得“不，我并没有做错”，从而减轻了对自己的压力。
which will be with you from 6 a.m on monday thank you so much take care of yourselves and i'll see you very soon bye if you're looking to become a psychologist Thank you. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些忐忑不安，我绝对推荐你看这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但是相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就绝对不会把它放下。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be OK. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐你看这本书，好让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，就绝对放不下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。